okay well for people watching this live
stream this is a continuation of a
design meeting about sparkle graph
databases and entity stores so we're
just talking about the relationship
between sparkle and graph databases and
so on and I think just to be clear I
mean the number one use of this for our
own purposes is to provide another
back-end for entity store is that
correct
yes that's one use case well okay so to
my knowledge there are two known use
cases
well maybe three one use case is
alternative backing for entity store
another use case is connecting to
existing Sparkle endpoints is that
correct
connecting sounds like a lot of setup
it's really directly querying them okay
query um okay and the final one is
[Music]
basically defining a system for graph
pattern matching
is that right I mean for I would see it
the other way around okay like like if
it would have a prince ledge crafted on
matching then that would go into here
but one could of course see it initially
this one would be an issue Kafka Don
Metro
yes well hold on hold on one second let
me just ask a question there and did did
Roger end up joining us now he preferred
to be on call but I can get him could
you could you ask him to actually join
us for a minute
yes thanks example you know where I'm
storing this stuff was that in Coffs
door I don't seem to have a thing called
craft store I thought that's what you
said yesterday oh no I have a thing
called Sparkle here okay okay alright so
my question for this is if we have a big
graph and we want to do matching on it I
mean is the implementation that we have
actually efficient for doing various
kinds of graph matching and you know
what's the right way to think about that
we have a big graph and it's an
in-memory graph that's working using our
standard graph mechanisms should we be
using this as the matching system or is
that silly so the graphs are completely
different a graph that is unlabeled and
these triple crafts or only of grass I
understand that I understand that but I
mean we we we need to go to a place
where our existing graph objects can
deal with labeling of the same kind that
we find in these triple graphs I would
think one command here is doing is that
if you're talking about efficiency then
most likely dedicated database engines
for the graph databases have vastly more
efficient implementations particularly
for these types of routes than we could
ever hope to get no no no I know
I know that's why I'm asking okay but
let's
look at this question I mean the so this
let's talk about alternative backings
for entity stores
okay so you know previously we have
talked about using our relational
database capabilities as an alternative
backing for data sets what is the state
of that lien that maybe you can say
something about that yes I actually
think that while we didn't pursue this
direction very far it is reasonably much
easier to do than what we are doing now
with the entities because what we have
now is an intermediate representation of
for the database queries to which we can
pile entities and even like you know
almost a year ago I suggested that we
could also compile data set language to
the same intermediate representation and
this is still true so whenever we want
to support data set but like you know
represent the relational database as a
bunch of data sets it will I think it
won't be that much work to compile data
set language to that intermediate
representation and the only thing we
will need to add really will be a
relational lookup hopping through the
tables as a single operation that would
extend the data set language that is
currently lacking okay so let me just
understand something so let's say I have
a random data set let me pick up a
random data set from somewhere yeah okay
let me go let's say I go to the data
repository I pick up a Wow no why do we
have a category called manufacturing if
we don't have anything underneath it who
knows
okay so let's say I pick something like
this up okay so right now
this is going to be what is this this is
the same thing I was seeing yesterday
does anybody know what this is a TI I
have heard many people are talking about
it so it seems to be a pretty wide
spread this year but I was told
yesterday that it was fixed well it is
maybe this version that I'm running here
is the wrong version um let's see if I
quit this than I have to let's quit out
of that um let's try this
current 11.3
you
you
okay let's try this again
I don't know why it's flashing that
thing it's not supposed to do that
okay fine so this is a random data set
okay currently in memory so my question
is what do we think this is going to
look like in a if it was backed by a
database okay so first of all one big
distinction between these use cases is
what are the types of the columns in
this data set as we can see here some of
the types are things like time series
which means that I mean right now what
we can do rather easily is to support
data sets which would be represented by
columns of the types that databases can
consume immediately mm-hmm that was the
whole point of the serialization binary
serialize yeah sure we can do that and
once we hook this up we could also
serialize time series as a binary thing
that will just store in the database the
only problem with this approach is that
you can then use database capabilities
to actually query that time series by
the means of databases you know then you
have to pull it out and do the same
standard data set query yes but the
other option might be and at some point
we may reach that option that it will be
possible to represent these objects in a
way there is more that would allow
databases to do certain queries using
their own I would think this is
something with the compiler for example
that we get closer to being able to
think about that complicated project I
think this will repeat for any objects
that's a little bit more complicated yes
one thing I want to mention is all right
now in the process of working with the
types because we need now to work out
the database types for our purposes we
are only also considering dealing with
composite types that would eventually
open the door to this kind of things
and it won't be very easy but it will
already now be in our framework the
potential capability to extend that to
actually treat those objects so in
particular the single data set
containing for instance column of time
series might be translated later on into
more than one table so that basically
you have a foreign key to fry right I
get it that's lovely but I mean for the
time being these are just glob it's a
binary serious and not going to
databases as such you're not going to
deal with images actually they can
because you can some of the databases
natively supports arrays support arrays
that's not an image I mean it's like
whatever I mean but okay what I'm trying
to understand is you know this is an
example so what would it look like if
this was you know this would be backed
by a database which is sitting either
locally or remotely yes yes yeah sure
and similarly in the sparkle case an
entity store could be backed presumably
I mean I understand we can have a local
sparkle thing running with our own
Sparkle endpoint server is that correct
Tony yes yeah that's actually an example
in the agenda they chose that so there's
one line if you scroll a little bit down
sparkle endpoint update you know this
shows how you start the server this is
just one command line and then you can
start reading and writing to Ted sparkle
endpoint which is running locally okay
and the idea for this would be something
similar right that you start a local
database server is that right if you
wanted to so I'm trying to understand if
I could potential
have I mean in the case where I'm
loading something from the data
repository for instance right there are
this data repository thing caches
locally in the file system right one
could imagine that instead or as well as
caching the serialized data locally in
the time I think it's caching an MX file
locally in the file systems anybody know
who did that infrastructure
that Nick or was it Bob I think it was
Bob santan Rick was it everything Bob
can somebody see if we can find Bob and
ask her about this Eric okay so what I'm
trying to understand is what this would
look like what the complete workflow for
the user would look like okay so for
example
they have a bunch of data they say okay
I want this stored it either comes from
the data repository as a database or
they decide to store it as a database or
a graph database or a sparkle thing and
then it would sit in the local object
store presumably or it could be a
cloud-based thing where they are simply
referring to some cloud endpoint am i
right I'll come back in just in a minute
I need to reboot ugly
okay am I right guys Tony
Michel Leonid I think so but I'm not
expert in this course
yeah looks like basically whatever at
storage specific stories you get you end
up with an energy store which will have
a handle and that handle can be
something you know local or remote but
it will write its task to to know how to
work with that handle right well I think
the resource system I stopped hi we are
talking about well we originally talking
about Sparkle endpoints and graft stores
okay but what we what we're now talking
about is in the resource system I load a
resource object and if I'm not mistaken
it's cached in the local object store is
that correct that's right
is it cached isn't an X file in the
local object store for data resources
yes neural net is still you on it and so
on different resource types have
different firmus okay all right so if we
were to cache a database there I'm a
little confused by how this would work
so imagine that this IC so so what could
happen is that something just like in
the data repository things can be entity
stores or there can be data sets so they
could also be in principle databases am
I am I right so far leonid well for a
data basis you basically need a database
server
unless it's an SQLite file and so you
will have to actually create a database
so if you you you don't really expose
that directly here because that database
server so there are two different
possibilities one is that from the data
repository you are going to load up a
clone of a database locally and the
other possibility is that you're
querying the single copy of the database
somewhere in the cloud is that right
yeah so I mean if it's a relational
database then I can't imagine you could
have a dump
as an SQL dump and that dump you could
store in the repository so the people
could download that and use that but
that's probably not what you meant you
meant something like a handle that is
directly queryable right no no there are
two cases one is that you clone it
locally and the other is so-so okay what
is the most common case of relational
databases the most common case will be
somebody has an existing database that's
been fed by some existing system and we
are merely querying it right now yeah
but you know if someone wants to give it
away for querying then either they have
to expose the database server to anyone
for the data repository yes for the
public data repository yes but in a in a
typical setting like at our company
we've got plenty of databases which you
know have a certain authentication and
then you can get to them and you can you
know read something from the bugs
database or whatever else it is right
yeah that's right so in you know in a
typical corporate setting what one would
expect is that one would have I mean
what one could have is some nice curated
list of relevant databases that's sort
of what we should have at our company
that if you have the appropriate
authentication you can connect to in the
language am I making sense yeah so
basically we have some kind of you know
connection objects which which would be
one could potentially have some handles
were one would just have to provide
extra authentication information to make
them what would be a nice way to do that
so if we had a you know a database
collection or something let's say that
in our private cloud we had a thing that
was like the data repository but was
essentially a database collection
database connection
collection then for each of those
databases we'd have a nice page which
explains how you get to you know what it
does blah blah blah it's effectively
documentation for the database and then
what we would expect on that page is
that there will be a connection object
and you copy paste that connection
object yeah and you'll need another
thing like authentication object or
something like that and when you combine
them together it will be a way to
automatically create connection from
that leave connection yes yes I
understand but I mean but I'm talking
about what the actual workflow of people
using this would be and one thing is
that you know somebody secretly sends
you an email that gives you information
about how to connect to that database
the other possibility is that we have a
more organized way of presenting on what
amount to you know repository pages
connection information for databases it
sounds similar we've talked about having
service connection repository
you know the good sounds more similar to
that than data unless you're taking snow
I agree with you I agree right what is
that what what have we thought through
how far have we thought through the
service connection repository we haven't
talked about designing web pages at all
if that's what you're asking
okay but yes you're right it's very
similar to that so fine and and
presumably now so let me ask this
question I mean in the in the general
world at large there are certain number
of Sparkle endpoints that are exposed
for general querying there are not I
suspect maybe I'm miss thinking about it
but people don't generally expose
database endpoints for general query
except insofar as web sites are you know
have database backing right but nobody
is exposing something which can be
connected to by our database connector
live over over HTTP or something Leonid
am i confusing something
well maybe the right few exceptions or
you know services which do that but
normally it goes through the layer of
you know representation layer so usually
people don't expose their
things that you can query by a SQL one
one actually or one notable exception is
for instance the stock exchange data
Explorer where we are actually going to
use it to as a testbed for for our
system where basically they expose
pretty much directly the interface where
you can write SQL query they give you
the schema of the whole stack exchange
database obviously that is a clone and
you can query the entire thing with all
the answers questions in situ are using
a scale but I don't know how direct is
that yeah that's a rare case even in the
case of sparkle it's slightly more
published you know endpoints but even
there we not looked and we're not seeing
very many Sparkle endpoints that are out
there in public in cases where people
expose things in many cases they might
actually put your query through certain
additional steps to enable time okay so
so okay but back to what we're talking
about here so another case so the case
is for databases is there is a database
it is typically a local corporate thing
it has your then you know for us you're
doing this database connect function if
I'm not mistaken that what we're calling
it yeah but it also is often found a lot
automatically for you by by the backend
sue unless you have a special needs to
actually do the connect yourself what is
it what does it look like how do you
reference the database then ah you
create the object that is called
database connection and then how do you
create that well you need for the
information basically the connection
string or you know the server the name
of the database and all those parts that
typically some kind of URI type things
yes it's some kind of your I type thing
and the only thing is normally you don't
provide the authentication straight in
there although you can and so yeah okay
but we have an authentic
option which presumably can use our our
authentication structures like username
and password or other kinds of things is
that right yeah well we didn't hook this
up yet but potentially sure what we
should do that I mean the database is
used things like oath or is that a
different technology stack again sorry
do they use things like oh no I don't
think they use that it's just just a
usual authentication through the
eventually it still becomes your string
so but so it's username and password
basically yes you should hook up the
authentication function and we've got
all these nice services like
authentication dialog which requests or
username and password etc etc yeah sure
um okay but I'm still walking through
what what we were actually doing with
this so then um let's see then I would
say you create any distortion it from
which from from your connection
information from your connection object
and then that any distort provides you
an interface to query a database yes
okay but now what you're saying is the
sparkle thing is an alternative way of
representing an entity store is that
right
Tony and
not directly but you can or will be able
to configure an entity store to consume
that order of data and presented as
entities there are some choices that can
be made and that has to be configurable
but wait a second I mean one of the
things we talked about is a use case for
this was to provide a backing for entity
stores yes exactly it's backing there is
no unique choice
so which subset of all the resources in
the early F graph are actually
considered entities which ones are
properties I see I see ok but but the
the raw use of a graph store is
something I mean how would okay walk me
through again so again with respect to
databases the 98% you know use case is
going to be people have an existing
database they're accessing it they want
to do things with the data in it that's
what is supported by you know didn't
lose connection things and then the
thing will show up in our system as an
entity store and we've built all of
these things like entity function and so
on
that allow you to manipulate the entity
store is that correct that's one
possibility well but leonid i mean
that's that's what you've been building
right yes so in the context of
relational databases that's workflow
right so okay so then for the graph
databases an alternative i mean there
are many fewer graph databases out in
the wild you know but one possibility is
you have a graph database out in the
wild and you want to use entity store
technology to query that graph database
is that a use case here
yes that's a possibility and in order to
have things not go bonkers it better be
the case that the entity store queries
that can be made through Leonids you
know that the database integration
system are the same set of queries or
those represent a subset or at least not
a okay how does the set of queries that
can reasonably be made through the thing
that is built on top of the relational
database
you know ORM system etc etcetera
etcetera
how do those queries relate to the
queries which are natural to make on a
graph database
well if you ask me then my very very
small understanding of RDF databases is
that one would be able to implement all
those primitives that we have introduced
in the context of relational databases
also for the route databases as well it
will be other things are only available
for graphs and which don't have a very
direct and Alex correlations and there's
the other way around is there other
things which can be done with relational
that are essentially impossible at the
graft case I don't think so I would
think that the graph case that the
relational case is a subset of the graph
case am i right yeah in the sense on the
other hand it has been shown that all
the graph like I think Sparkle could be
compiled down to SQL instance so yes so
that's our translation in both
directions so because each triple graph
you can just store it as one large table
so in principle there's always a
translation yes I understand that but I
mean in practice for us when we have
things like entity function and all
these kinds of things do we imagine Tony
that your system will support those or
so I have already started experimenting
with that so that should work so all the
new entity functions that we are
introducing for the relational backend
should work with RDF ok that's cool
that's really cool but now what
additional functions could you support
with the graph back-end that are not
reasonable to support with a rational
back-end
I mean a lot of these these you know
paths of related entities surely are
hard to support yeah and actually soon
there is one very important thing here
is that for all relational queries we
really need to know the schema exactly
as a rigid thing and because our sparkle
and points don't necessary schema then
obviously those queries which you know
are formulated in terms of not like not
referring to the schema we won't we'll
have hard time doing that relational
world just because we you know I get it
okay so my question then is what okay
so if we've got an entity store like
we've got various random entity stores
in the data repository like the crazy
one like Nathan's crazy one with
amniotes and things and you know
properties of animals or something
that particular one for example seems
naturally like a rational something that
could be stored in a relational database
so do we have examples of things in the
data repository which are not
conveniently stored in a relational
database but which are naturally stored
in a sparkle type world
as an audio F triple store or something
I'm not sure there's one person here you
can answer that I think the things that
we put in data repository are mostly the
ones that fit okay fair enough
okay but but so walk me through if we
were going to go out in the world and
find things that would naturally be
represented in a in a sparkly way what
would we what would we find
I mean example our own our own surf is
an example semantic relations framework
is an example of something that yeah
what's are some examples of use right
now for Sparkle for these RDX well what
we've got here is Tony wrote down this
list of public Sparkle endpoints like
wiki data like this European art thing
like musicbrainz
I mean honestly very short list so far
it's a short list and I know you know
we've been tracking this for years it's
always been a short list now you know
there was a big excitement about sparkle
in US government circles maybe a decade
ago or something and I don't know how
much actually got built out from that um
so when
checklist here I went to some random
German unicorn library website and
downloaded their catalogue of all books
as a turtle file that this was a one
gigabyte file of the whole catalogue and
guess that we will be able to process
such data at that point importer was too
slow to actually finish but we are
getting close to being able to import
such big files so you import a one
gigabyte turtle whatever that might be I
mean that's a heck of a lot of books
right one gigabyte I mean a typical
library might a big library might have
five million books and each book has
probably a page worth of data at most so
I'm not understanding how you get to a
gigabyte of or unless they have like
cover images and things it's a lot of
relations yeah but yeah what are in
million books I mean what are you
represented what what does that triple
what is it like the books and the
authors and the birth dates and what a
typical Bible graphical information
right but this will be what's in the
triple you know because there's a triple
there's three things our saw of the book
was six so I was off book and he sees
things well the connection would be
usually author has written yes and then
book and they has written is Lee is the
edge and the author and the book are
nodes I see now where as in a relational
setup that would be simply you know in
the table of in the list of authors and
in the list of books a you know a
property would be the author and that's
a particular thing and that would then
be a key potentially into a you know
foreign key into another database am i
right yes and if there is a multiple to
multiple relations and there will be
intermediate table which will
essentially be that edge which is here
presented by a written body and in
relational setting if you have many too
many that region by age would basically
correspond to an intermediate table okay
okay I think that for things that are
mostly rectangular in nature so you go
to all these species you missiles there
are master running speed this will not
true of any of its power but if you have
anything that kind of more real and
organic like like the sciences itself
like the ceilings of mass or even the
network of our source they are Israel is
non-trivial network structure comes into
play okay but but so you're saying let's
say that a bunch of nodes that represent
people yeah like what your relation to
Newton but the shortest paths
yeah yeah right so there is another
thing here as well that whoever makes a
structured relational database out from
all the data they make certain choices
which impose which which reflect how
they choose the schema and then in this
sparkle world you don't have to make
those choices no I understand but but
let's talk about the relation now to
graphs so for example a social network
you know has a bunch of nodes that
represent people but the edges of the
social network are purely some kind of
friend connection or link in LinkedIn or
whatever else it is right so there's
kind of only one type of edge if I'm not
mistaken there can model all kinds of
things but but
what exactly that is you say when you
build the graph when you when you know I
really the point is that the the sweet
spot of the audio of triple business is
there isn't just one type of edge there
are lots of types of edges and you know
in other words might the claim that I'm
making is most of the stuff we do with
graphs and networks involves effectively
one type of relation like is a friend of
or is linked to still but it's only on
the surface then you can see that there
are different ways of how people link to
you know could be personal it could be
something else I'm aware but but the
fact is in you know in the way that we
are currently are graph theory functions
okay mostly do not allow that
possibility right graph theory functions
are built to analyze mostly graphs where
there's one type of edge is that a fair
statement Roger well that's an
interpretation of it you you you know
effectively it's a binary relation yes
you know and how you choose to to what
that binary relation models there are
many ways in which you you take a enery
relation into binary relations sure but
but my point Roger is that that that
binary relation yeah it is a binary
relation that is the edge is merely a
relate or of two things right but for
instance you can one way to take let's
say that we have a ternary relation yeah
you know or you have an intermediate
node or something that you can take the
union of two binary relations so then
the edge means that or that or dad's
fine I get it but my point is what the
you know the set of functions the
hundred functions are something that we
have for graph theory mostly dealing
with I mean the via see here that's
coming up is if we're extending our you
know on the one hand there's our pattern
language on the other hand there's the
graph theory stuff yes and what's
happening here
this is somewhere in between those two
so we're talking about things like graph
cases but we could imagine a graph cases
that is merely for our binary relation
style graphs
well is that could be a graft cases
where you say you know where things are
connected like the the nodes the people
you know there could be a person who is
a you know can one connect you know how
is by a purely by the friend relation
how is this person who was a boy scout
connected to this person who climb Mount
Everest or something yeah um your I
think that these very data oriented sort
of uses of relations like the enery
relations of relational databases and
they're still binary it's just a big
super binary relations it seems to me
did the triple fair enough yeah yeah
yeah okay but look what I'm trying to
get to is what is the sweet spot use
case for the triple store thing and how
does it relate to on the one hand our
graph stuff on the other hand our
database stuff and entity store stuff
okay
because otherwise we don't know where I
mean you know we could try to build out
something I think that one could try to
enumerate cases well that's what I was
talkin to do earlier in this meeting
yeah but but I mean the triple store
case seems to me a lot of I mean look I
can imagine all kinds of funky you know
law enforcement style or you know
financial you know how is this connected
you know how is the how is an earthquake
happening here going to be related to
you know the price of an iPhone you know
a month later because this is connected
to that is connected to that and the
relation might be you know there is a
mine that is in this particular place
where the earthquake happened and that
mine is the supplier of stuff to this
place and that supplier you know
connects that that stuff that is you
know I don't know tantalum is used in
some weird rare earth magnet that's used
in this that's used in that etc etc and
somehow you've got it so I can imagine
that there are you know so it seems like
this triple service is like a sparse way
to represent all of those possible
relations you know because it's right
yeah yeah and as the query language
cancer can probably go a certain ways to
use those relations well as look the
query language Roger has graph matching
so for example this boy scout and Mount
Everest example well no let's take this
some you know you can say how is this
connected to that what is the path that
connects this to that you can say Tony
correct me if I'm wrong you can you can
give some pattern features of that path
and say give me a path that has these
types of edges in it or something like
that is that right yes it's basically a
regular expression language on the
properties let's see I can see how we
can convert I'd away
Maceo we can sort of extract the graph
of something of interest that we then
have other kinds of analysis tools that
are available and I can see how we can
take a graph and and and inject it as a
triple store yes yes I agree but I mean
the point about the graph is our generic
graphs have only one type of edge that
first statement Roger I mean we have a
convenient way and we're talking about
introducing such a thing um and that's
one reason I wanted you or charles here
is that you know we've been talking
about the possibility of having a what
did we call it some kind of what we call
it yesterday graph edge or something and
we had you know a potential i mean that
is something which appearance-wise will
be a and then you know our arrow b and
then this this edge will be annotated
with something make sense um so for
instance but are there Gruffalo h labels
i mean but is it purely visualization
because you know to get all the
operations to work properly with that is
massive oops that is funny what just
happened that um you know this is the
big problem isn't to just you know I
mean visualization is a problem but but
the big problem is to define meaning for
these hundreds of operations know I
realized that I realized that so the
possibility but that's what the sparkle
business is doing
it is dealing with graphs that have
labeled edges if I'm not mistaken and
there's certain operations that so so
for example let's imagine you don't
graph isomorphism with labeled edges
that's a whole different world from
graph isomorphism without labelled edges
yeah and you know so Tony you've
enumerated certain operations that are
[Music]
you know there are ones that are
conveniently thought about in terms of
these labelled graphs is that right
so yes do you have a list of those
someplace in here if you call a little
bit down on about the middle one yes I
mean but there's a question whether
they're still I mean it's you know I
would say that they're probably not
recognized as graphs anymore sorry for
that what was this work where are we
going here further cut up further up so
it's still in the section RDF okay but
this is this seems relevant here these
are the sparkle patterns so there may be
ten different pattern types that Sparco
supports right yeah so I mean so there's
a relation between sparkle select or
sparkle ask the sparkle pattern matcher
and a potential graph cases function and
when I looked into it I understood
there's some intersection of
functionality that they have but there
are certain things in graph cases that
can't be easily or maybe not at all be
done in sparkle and vice versa for
instance the concept of sub-queries in
Spokeo wouldn't it wouldn't be possible
to fit it into something like graph
cases unless we introduced something
some completely new pattern constructs
for instance things that allow
processing of the pattern on the left
hand side of the rule yes
I've dealt a lot with weird ternary
relations because they effectively model
finite automata whether those are
deterministic or non-deterministic you
know because the only edges there's a
symbol it is you know exactly you know
and but they're not graphs I mean you
can sort of you know they're just not
graphs what the heck are they then you
know I mean not hypergraph sighted you
know I have we have tons of literature's
and graphs and they are certainly not
acknowledged as graphs
yes so the most mathematical description
we have come up with so far is they're
ordered directed hyper graphs ready edge
links is always 3/4 that director type
of graphs ok well there are three I
think that's the core technical
description right thing you know I mean
but it's a good thing but it's it's
better to recognize that they are
they're related but they are a different
thing and don't try to force force it's
it's like saying that yeah we have
tensors but they're really matrices
we're gonna treat them all as matrices
you know and there are some big bunch of
areas of science to do just that
yeah ok but but but so ok labeled edge
labeled graphs aka triple stores
is one possible construct that we could
have where we could do certain graph
theoretic operations on it I mean like
connectedness or something that's a
perfectly reasonable concept for that
see the main issue is in typical graph
theory stuff that we do
we're gulping the whole graph down in
one go and doing something to it in the
typical way that you're using sparkle
you're absolutely not doing that you're
picking away at some particular you know
path in the graph or something like that
sure and it's the same sense in which
you know in a you know in one of our
data sets you've got the whole thing
there versus something where there's a
remote database and you're picking away
at some piece of it that's not a great
analogy but yeah I mean similarly with
the entity store there's a question of
whether you're picking away at some
particular entity and property or
whether you are gulping the whole entity
store and analyzing it all right so
where are we going with this so so what
what we I'm trying to understand there
are you know certain cases in which
you've got you know just a bunch of
triples I mean in our how should we
think about this
I mean we've got things like our
existing you know semantic relations
framework which is pretty organized into
entity property value type setups it's
not a free-floating collection of random
triples and you know in the things that
I mean
I can see situations in which it's very
useful to know I mean look if it's how
is this connected to that
okay so again okay let's say we're
trying to analyze I don't know what
effect you know the earthquake in
wherever has on the you know price of a
no SmartWatch six months later or
something at some level we can just
think about that in terms of a graph
because the fact is the connectivity you
know there's probably limited enough
connectivity that if we just you know
had the nodes in a graph we'd say okay
there's a there are paths in the graph
great there's a part in the graph now
let's understand what was actually on
those edges and so on yeah I mean the
case that is the sort of the
quintessential Sparkle case is asking
these questions where you are
constraining which edge you go down
I'm a making sense in other words it's
not it's you know there's a set of
problems where basically the very
existence of any edge is already
interesting because there are fairly few
edges but you know let's imagine that we
are um you know let's do the
bibliographic case okay the person who I
mean again it's a question of what is
the query that we're trying to you know
I mean a question would be I mean one
thing that you get from from when when
your model sort of systems and machines
that transition edge it's it's some
action yes so what so then you know a
question that you often want to answer
this you know give me to set the
reachable States right it's not a
sparkle question it's not a sparkle
style question right basically all the
possible end points given that you start
over here what are the things I can
write right can they can the aeroplane
land without its undercarriage down or
whatever something like that you know um
or given these two points can I can I
get from here to there which is you know
you've can formulate in in graphs to but
you know it's yes but I mean but those
are questions that those are look the
the case that is more likely sparkle the
quintessential Sparkle case you're
really using the labels of the edges
because you're asking a question that is
you know the author who
operated with somebody who was the
student of who was the whatever who came
from such and such a a a country which
was the descendant of such-and-such of
the Ottoman Empire which was the blah
blah blah blah blah but would you
example just showed they were not trust
or labor d'etre some of them were 18
nodes I see a sign so it's a mix of both
Grady metal sometimes I want to go a
certain edge but sometimes you also want
to go to a certain note right but so in
the case of wolf now for queries we
haven't we have profoundly not found
these kinds of things useful or an su is
that a fair statement I would say we
haven't found them common yes I think
they are useful but that does not
comment well I mean but but we have you
know we are currently able to support
queries I mean you know there's a
trade-off right because expressing the
thing in natural languages can be quite
kind of funky
I mean I'm I'm I am quite confused
because these these cases when there's
some Sparkle use cases in like the under
some medical Sparkle use cases like like
on these things like the yeah for
instance an example I've worked on some
time ago was redoing some experiments
about direct repurposing they were
looking at different past types that
exists between different types of nodes
like genes and tissues and expression
and so on and then they were training a
neural net to figure out which past
types are indicative of a certain
chemical being useful the tree
a certain illness good and then they
were able to ability certain new
candidates that were later yeah but
realistically this is not a triple store
story I mean something like okay so I'm
going to give two examples so something
like that case of you know jeans tissues
snips whatever else those are a small
number of types of thing and they are
very structured that is you know jeans
are in certain tissues so think of a
it's almost like the author case but
like a music database here's the song
who's the artist what else has this art
is done yeah but that's a trivial thing
for us to answer without triple storing
anything
I mean that's a trivial relational kind
of question isn't it
well okay the case lime service although
so the whole point about the drug
repurposing example was that it
integrated a lot of databases like 25 or
30 different databases and they
investigated something like a sultan
past types which had many more instances
yeah I understand so another case that
might work that way is an Anatomy
database because you know there are you
know a few thousand structures maybe
four or five thousand structures but
their relations are kind of random and
complicated or am i you know light like
this bone is connected to this joint
which has this tendon you know in it and
I can imagine a case where that would be
yeah where are we relevant to ask one of
these sort of sparkle like questions
it's pretty you know like ligaments and
tendons don't they all have just
insertion points and you know they have
two insertion points all of them pretty
much
yes but doesn't that define I mean yeah
I'm trying to think about the question
I'm um yes okay you take to be different
anatomical structures and say how do
they interact with each other yeah fair
enough
because there might be they might not
directly visit although your left column
level right but again okay all right so
let's again zoom out why are we doing I
mean what are we gonna use Sparkle for
we've got entity stores and one
possibility is that entity stores
okay so entity stores one representation
is relational databases the claim is
there are certain kinds of entity stores
that are not well represented by
relational databases and for which if
somebody throws us one of those entities
stores we are better off presenting it
as a you know through a graph database
or through spark or RDF triples then we
are representing it as a relational
database is that a fair statement I
don't quite know what the
characterization of that thing is so
personally I think we don't have to say
that it doesn't fit into relational
schema so that's why we use the graph
schema I think it's a very nice way to
store data and I personally find writing
Sparkle queries really easy and I found
myself fixing data and Viki data just by
writing directly sparkled queries and
then post-processing it in the Wolfram
language that was really convenient so I
see it as a you know nice query language
and a nice format to store the data
independent of whether it fits into
relational databases or not
to store what kind of data any kind of
data so because whenever you have some
information you want to store you can
always put it in the one or the other
and there might be no strong argument
but there might be arguments like
convenience or preference so where is
sparkle winning so to speak where is it
popular I I think it's in various
complex business process type things in
various government type situations but
I've not seen you know I don't think
it's a huge growth area right now but
where was it born I I thought it was
sort of born from Semantic Web and those
kinds of things ah DF was a creature of
the Semantic Web I think in many ways
and I think yes and the ideas that every
resource that means the things that
appear in the subject predicate or
object position ir ice that means if
different people publish their data set
and reuse the same III that means you
automatically know it's the same
resource yeah it's linking data
integrating different data sets and it's
what Tim berners-lee thought was going
to be sort of a follow-on to the web
that hasn't really happened you know so
more and more vocabularies are being
published for instance just recently the
time ontology has been published and I
found it useful to reuse in just
examples in this notebook the time
ontology once or twice time as in Time
magazine in the sense of before after
duration and so on Oh completely
different but so I don't understand that
I mean that that's the type of thing
where we are you know building support
for you know temporal logic and all
those kinds of things which it's not
just an ontology it's got more it's not
you know to call it ontology is is kind
of silly I think yes so the ideas with
our building functionality for dates and
times when we import such the data set
we automatically know what what they
mean in the data if they reused
for instance a time ontology no but wait
a second
you know the time ontology is not going
to handle things like it happens every
Tuesday after you know every I don't
know what every first Tuesday of the
month
it's not going to be the type of thing
that's in the time ontology is it I have
to check that I don't know it I'm sure
not I'm sure it's not I'm sure it's a
simplified version I mean you know what
we've discovered in trying to implement
a bunch of these time related things and
time granularity and time inclusion and
time intervals and repeating events and
so on it's pretty complicated and it is
one of these things that like so many
other things we deal with you can think
of as an you know an algorithmic set of
relations not a purely sort of static on
total ontological set of relations well
quickly looking at ontology it seems to
be able to represent repeating events
and so on but it shouldn't be thought of
as an ontology it needs to be an
algorithm I mean it's you know what's
gonna do two things to consider one is
just making a statement when things not
happening or in which border the other
thing is reasoning about these
statements the ontology is just for
stating two things why will this
eventually happen well no no you know
look if if things happen the first
Tuesday of every month how many of them
will happen before Easter good luck the
time ontology I don't want to say too
much because I don't know at Denver but
it's built on owl and the plan is to
extend sparkle to support our ontology
that means we will be able to do some
reasoning about it but this is still in
the future yeah I you know look I think
that this idea is it's funny I happen to
be writing a proto blog post about
things to do with foundations of logic
and this seems to me one of these yet
another one of these cases where people
you know yes logic was a good idea
starting with Aristotle and so on but
does it really is it really the way I
mean this is one of these let's
represent the world using you know these
specific
models of ontology and I don't know
anyway we can we can yacon
philosophically about it but that's
probably not what we should do and we're
late anyway right now okay so what is
the practical direction we're gonna go
with all of this stuff I mean it seems
like what you're doing right now Tony is
to build essentially a semi-independent
package that can handle you know sparkle
connections RDF things like that you
know very much tied into the vernacular
of sparkle and an RDF so and I think
that's probably fine and I think it's
worth go ahead I call it this is
definitely number one kinda have a
representation of this that we can go to
the outside world and connect also and
then I feel like step two is use this
one as a first version to clearly entity
stores with queries that we currently
don't form I cannot even form and of
course although answering this and then
once we have some experience with this
and see what we really want then we can
involve leasing on which part of the
sparkle coughs Norbeck take sparkles
world do we really need to clearly
entity stores
okay so fine but so then then what we
would do is maybe we should package some
of these public Sparkle endpoints as
service connections just so that we have
a way to introduce them and document
them in the system I mean in other words
that would be a very shallow and wrapper
because it's just a URL
I see it would be maybe did not bet
having kinda like something that is a
URL but have this party eight point
somehow wrapped around well but I mean
the point that Tony is making his stuff
is gonna be in some particular context
and I mean the only point that I'm
making is um so look it sounds like your
project that what should happen is you
know we should package it up it should
be its own package a sparkle package and
that then we'll see whether people can
use it with existing sparkle resources
and then what Michael was saying is the
next question of how this sort of finds
its way into either our graph theory
stuff and or entity store stuff seems
still a bit uncertain do know ok we'll
explain it okay
take one of our bigger entity stores and
ask us to like how do you come from
point A to B we couldn't form this query
right now okay fair enough but that
requires language design for how to
specify that query yes but what I'm
saying
mr. spark is one we could already format
right now yes but in this sparkle ask
there's no other thing then we have to
think what is our version of it okay if
you have a talking implementation
already okay so then what you're saying
is we could imagine a function that
takes an entity store may be one that's
in the data repository may be another
one and converts it into a sparkle into
something represented in sparkle with a
local sparkle server running queering
it's that which was suggestion that's
not even necessary yes that you register
an entity store like any other entity
store and you apply this Parker query to
it at least in the first step usually
have more Wolfram language like function
then we can apply to the entities to
but the ideas that we can apply directly
as Puckle select to an entity but the
entity store is stored how is it stored
as Sparkle or is it stored in the usual
way it doesn't matter so the ideas that
you can have an in-memory entity store
and the queries are appropriately
translated or you have an already effect
entity store and then there's no I know
but how would you get an audience back
tensity store there two approaches that
we are considering right now one is from
the database people having a second
argument of entity store in which you
define the backend or having an RDF
entity store where did it come from did
it come because it was presented to you
you know from the beginning of time that
way you know from the outside world or
did it come because you constructed you
know let's imagine I made an entity
store that represented some mathematical
thing where I just constructed every
piece myself does it end up being RDF
represented or does it end up being the
way we're representing it into the store
right now well that wouldn't change so
you would probably just get a typical
entity store okay if you're constructing
the entities manually there's no need to
convert it into re F what you're saying
is that the only way to get an RDF
entity's store is to already have an
audience list or in some sense yes okay
but so then the question is where did
the idea I mean it's like the Turtles
all the way down question especially
with this like you know representation
called turtle but where did the where
did the original RDF entity store come
from in other words what we've what
we've determined is that there aren't
that many public Sparkle endpoints etc
and we're also concerned like within our
company I don't believe we have any idea
you know any naturally occurring RDF you
know collections
triple stores we have plenty of well we
have some graph databases we have plenty
of many many ordinary relational
databases we have many things that are
just tables of various kinds but I don't
think we have any naturally-occurring
triple stores um except maybe the few
things we have in golf databases but so
my question is where are people going to
get their triple stores from it's not
that I could take existing entity stores
and asked complicated questions on it
okay but that then requires that we
convert them to audit to triple stores
to be able to ask those questions no no
okay
so I'm confused somehow so with the
existing internal representation of
entity stores you can somehow run the
sparkle magic and yes
so in the worst case the entity stores
converted on to fly into an RDF graph
okay various important cases we can
translate it into more efficient entity
queries that means we don't have too
much he realized the graph and we just
keep it as an entity store so you're
saying so one one thing we should do
then is write down in terms of entity
function all these kinds of things
there's certain kinds of queries that
the relational you know back-end can
handle and for which we have invented
things like entity function because
those are convenient for asking
relational type questions so similarly
there is presumably and that's what we
started looking at with graph cases and
so on there is presumably I mean the
question is if we're just going to query
entity stores we're not trying to make
this general for graphs we're just
trying to query entity stores with these
paths for example is there a convenient
Wolfram language representation of a
path query and an entity store is that
the right question to be asking maybe
because very similar things really come
up this the molecule we should be
slightly more general it shouldn't be
maybe as general as default off sync but
slightly more general than this because
we want to see in a molecule is there a
certain chain of atoms
yeah I understand so you're suggesting
so why don't we try to have you already
addressed this question Tony or to make
a language level design for something
that corresponds to a path in the triple
store yes some idea that it would be a
property past pattern or something like
that but that would be for something
like graft cases to have something for
an entity no there is an idea something
like an entity property path or sequence
but we haven't sorted out yet actually
we have a number of interesting comments
on our live stream here let me just go
through these and we're gonna wrap this
up soon okay so graph ledger seems neat
oh it's once trying to make a graph of
the interstate system I was hoping to
give edge lengths like I 94 that's
interesting I mean don't we have a way
of weighting the edges of a graph right
now Roger sorry don't we doesn't have a
way of giving weights for hours muted
right um okay so sparkle seems very much
to be find this sub graph in this giant
horrible graph yeah to some extent
um okay somebody
resource with sparkle query examples
somebody is giving us let's take a look
at what they sent discovered asteroids
by countries yeah okay fine I mean again
that's not really that's not deeply
triple istic that's just a one-shot
thing I think kind of a disappointing
collection of languages there
what is this anyway open datasets in
Paris okay um yeah entities could become
a giant triple story yes we know this um
yeah somebody is pointing out the entity
system in wolf's mind which is more
graph shape than relational database
shaped for sure and even our datasets
obviously a deep and hierarchical in a
way that relational databases are not
naturally um actually I wouldn't be so
sure that the entities as they exist are
more towards graphs I would say I think
I think I mean it's the set of all of
them yes because I think they're also
very nature of the relational as well
okay so somebody's pointing out triple
stores the best way to add structure to
messily structured data yeah kind of I
mean you know if you get stuff from
natural language or something you can
make them up I just have not seen
somebody says here I did a case study
against that unguided data Microsoft let
loose not quite sure what that means
um
I will allows you to combine recoveries
yes to create one metal ontology um
you
let's see do entity stores have unique
so somebody is asking to enter these
stores have unique persistent IDs for
their names properties values if so it'd
be trivial to construct your eyes for
the industry properties and trivial to
create RDF from those your eyes yes the
answer is yes they have the the I mean
it's somewhat complicated because
there's but but yes we have our entities
are intended to be unique permanent
things well with the footnote that if
people start creating them
you know let's see locally have every 10
people can locally have the same entity
and mean something different yes they
can locally bill I but we have this
mechanism for generating new you IDs
right for the our external reference
mechanism generates you you IDs we
haven't the you know we we have
certainly designed something along these
lines where people where two people can
generate entities that they locally both
refer to as I don't know a particular
species of monkey or something but we
don't necessarily know whether those
people really mean the same thing but
for them locally they've got you you IDs
and then at some point in the future
somebody can come in and do the grand
unification and say your two monkey
species are actually the same species um
but that's obviously a separate step and
a complicated step if two sets of people
have their own ontology x' anyway let's
see yeah so in this case you can build a
so-called link set say this ID is the
same as this ID using for instance the
whole vocabulary same s okay alright
listen we got a wrap so which context
should it be the last time you suggested
graphs or context
well what do you think Michael what do
you think given or should it admit it's
more sparkly I personally like it
because the might in the future thing
about adding other graph languages for
instance gremlin or cheek or or whatever
and this could all be in the grass no
context no okay my IP opted we have them
in their corresponding overall name okay
all right sounds good
all right we should look at this again I
I feel like we have not fully resolved
the strategy of what we're doing here I
mean this was very useful for me and
understanding more about how these
different you know ways to represent
data fit together but I feel like we're
not I mean it sounds like we've got one
definite thing which is to introduce an
entity world path you know whatever you
call it property path pattern whatever
you're going to call it didn't we
already have something of that type what
we're already talking about that don't
we already have a property path thing
that's used in the relational setup we
were discussing it but we are still for
the relational part we're still have to
come to relations once again and start
using that actually so we were only
discussing the name so far okay but I
mean that particular thing would be a
thing that would be kind of a front and
center type feature in the case of
triple stores but not a you know but a
thing that is relevant but not so
highlighted in the relational case is
that a fair statement I think not
because in there in the relational
statement it's also very very relevant
okay but it won't have patterns in the
relational case so will it unknown are
no patterns right oh though you couldn't
principle make patterns it would just be
rather inefficient and silly
yeah well the problem is the batteries
won't be able to query for instance the
edges so to speak because the edges in
relational world translates to you know
specific kind of names of the tables
right why don't we
why doesn't Tony have a think about how
that could be set up for the triple
store representation of these graphs and
then let's discuss this again seemed
reasonable and let's meanwhile get this
graph store stuff actually implemented
documented etc so we can let people try
and start using it yes okay
all right good stuff thanks a lot guys
ok bye